so now his front is fitting my back so
if you like the width and the
width if you're here like this I haven't
got the width so by turning this foot
and turning this like that I turn all of
this so This actually is fitting so
there's a lot more my we'll say my back
fitting his belly so that's what I'm
doing I'm giving more of his skin to fit
more my skin rather than it being a
blade against the wide part and that's
why turn so so almost everybody is
having this problem where they're going
in about here they think that's enough
but you see it's a thin piece against a
wide
piece so why why you have to motivate
yourself cuz nobody's going to do it for
you you have come here you have to spin
all the way around so now now I don't
know if to see there's a lot more now on
my
back
on so that's that's basically the the
gist of
it okay
so so until he gets his foot in that
final
position get his foot in that final
position that come in time
just keep remembering that's that's I
don't what pag is in my book but I go
into detail a bit about it but you do
have to I've done this technique for
years so I'm a bit Rusty on it but what
I do now is you've got that or youve got
that and you're try to get that the only
way you can do it is by turning your own
body for that you need that foot to open
up then you bring them bring him and
yourself back around and again I was
saying when I first started tonight
about
flexibility and that's why you need
flexibility that's why you need your
yoga you need your stretching you need
your warmups you need to maximize and
find out what your body can achieve not
well this is the best I can do you know
you have to go beyond
that than
you one hand one hand I could pull him
all night but if I co coordinate this
knee and that that CW then I get it and
I just give a little twist like that so
I
can't if I do it together and then I
just turn it like that I lock it so as
he tries to come back you lock
it and just try three on each side so
try that first and then you can see if
you can all the way and just it goes
round it goes
round away from you okay so here's
the we'll say the expansion expansion
okay